you know you're in Mark Zuckerberg inner
circle is that a bad thing to be in Mark
Zuckerberg center sir I don't know what
it means
exactly I feel it's good that I have a
lot of history with Mark I understand
him and I feel like I can actively
advocate for Instagram when that makes
sense and I can also better explain to
people who work at Instagram what Mark's
intentions are because I spent so much
time with him no here's one thing Chris
Hayes former co-founder this made a lot
of news I know you're aware of this
described mark as a good kind person but
his focused on growth led him to
sacrifice security civility for cliques
and worried now that mark has surrounded
himself with a team that reinforces his
beliefs instead of challenging him do
you feel you can challenge Mark
Zuckerberg
I certainly do as I feel like I
challenge him on a regular basis I think
I don't expect you to say no Gayle I
don't feel yeah yeah I don't know from
New York if anything I'm worried that
I'm a little bit too pushy on these
types of things of course no one's gonna
my position is gonna say absolutely not
I don't feel comfortable challenging
wrong exactly but I look I think that I
think I think I challenge him and he
challenges me he has a high bar for me
he's a high bar for everybody who works
here and I think that's a good thing and
when I disagree with him I try to be
very honest about that and I honestly I
think he appreciates that because some
of the information that comes to him I'm
sure does come through some sort of
filter yeah what do you think it is what
do you think it is Adam that people
don't understand about him as someone
who knows him as someone who knows him I
mean it's hard to say because I my
experiences of what people think about
him are through this crazy filter well
here's what I'd say I think he holds
people to a high bar and I think that's
good I think he's very thoughtful and
intentional about what role he thinks we
can play in the world in people's lives
and over the long run and he's very very
willing to make decisions that he thinks
are the right ones for people and for
what we do even if it means that the
business is gonna get hurt in the short
term or there any a criticism in the
short term etc so I guess the thing I
would think is that he's a very very
long-term a green he's very very rude
first principles mm-hmm and I think
that's good I really do the big
conversation now is has Facebook gotten
too big Facebook Instagram whatsapp it's
just gotten too big too out of control
has too much power regulation is needed
what do you say to that
I think regulation is needed I think we
are at a scale now where the decisions
we make affect a lot of people's lives
on a daily basis we're trying to welcome
regulation and engage with different
policy makers we have a responsibility
to create value for the people who use
our services every day to be open and
honest and transparent about what we do
and how we do it we have responsibility
to do what we can to keep people safe on
our platform given that we know that
that if that happens on our platforms is
always good so the way we think about it
is we try to embrace that responsibility
and do our best to live up to it every
day I haven't heard mark say he's in
favor of regulation of you he talked
about it a few months ago he posted
about four areas election safety who
content definition problems are content
problems privacy and data portability
were the four areas that we're actively
trying to engage we just and by the way
we were regulated in different ways in
different countries already there are
laws about certain things that happen on
Instagram or on Facebook so I think
regulation it can be a very good thing I
just think we want to make sure that
it's done well do you like the title
head of Instagram as opposed to CEO of
Instagram I'm not too worried about the
title you're not hung up about that no
I'm focused on the rare it's very rare
for someone in your position you're
saying what does it change huh what are
the change you'd be surprised how hung
up people get about their titles at him
I believe it I believe it but for me no
discussion about it like he had the CEO
title shouldn't have CEO title you had
no discussion about that I didn't I
didn't I was focused on I like I said it
was a crazy week I wanted to make sure
that the team was in a good place
I wanted to seek out the job I did I did
when when when Mike and Kevin left and
everybody found out in a rush I talked
to Mike and Kevin about how about coming
in and spending time with the team
because I needed to see that yeah hi and
then I also said look I
love this job but what's more important
than me getting this job is that someone
gets the job or that there's some clear
process for picking someone that's
public soon because we can't does not
have a leadership yeah exactly and so I
was pushing on that so the title wasn't
well it wasn't maybe it should have been
top of mind but honestly I'm I'm blessed
in a lot of ways I try to you know be
grateful for what I have and to me that
it's not particularly important let me
say I don't Masseria you are a different
kind of dude in a very good way I'll
tell you